should I make a be a sensible young
murder you know it doesn't get better
than that
what's up GQ is your boy murder beats
and these are my essentials my number
one essential today is my cook up setup
where I make all my music I'm about to
build my cook up station Eunos and my
laptop just cause like if I did everyone
individually it's like a little too much
nose eraser interface rme baby face you
know I'm saying if you want to make
beats like me now you got to get our IV
babyface it's a chord you need one of
these straight beats portable speaker I
stole from a hotel in New York you can't
find these anymore like that you know so
it's a Persian rug mouse pad you know so
whenever you see this in a studio you
know what's going down it's just like
easier to like get all like the plugins
and stuff on like a Windows computer and
like that's kind of like what I started
on but now I think that I think they
made it a lot easier
she's like Apple now for stuff because
before FL studio' wasn't on Macs and
stuff so people were like partitioning
their stuff
yeah it's like a little like four-minute
beat not bad
my next essentials slides I always use
size all the time
airports in the house out Studios
wherever I go you know saying gotta keep
some slides on day socks to the slides
no songs with the slides depends on fit
you know I usually go socks if I'm like
in the backyard or going to the beach
going in the pool and stuff obviously no
songs cuz you're off-white you could
tell that they're everyday like they're
kind of worn out most of stuff I brought
they're like worn out everyday
essentials
sometimes when I'm drunk or something it
gets confusing oh yeah they're like the
wrong way neck's essential it's a white
oak alone you know saying it smells good
I like spray here and then like I'll get
on both sides and then I'll spray here
and get it right here and then I spray
like walk into it it's a whole lot
always you know say everyday put some
Cologne on never know who you're gonna
bump into what meeting you're gonna have
to run in on shout out my boy capo he
put me on this cologne you know zan I
don't know ever since just gonna been
wearing this they're doing a lot of good
stuff in my life so I probably been
wearing this remote maybe like two years
now I remember like when I was a kid my
mom would always get me like Cologne for
Christmas so I was like I think put off
I didn't really like it when I was a kid
[Music]
Carlinhos in definite need some
chapstick all the time let's get chapped
you never know you know he said I wasn't
gonna make sure you go good honestly
it gives it like a little like cool
feeling I like that go get his wallet
gotta keep your cards and your ID and
some money and you know I'm saying it's
definitely a big essential I actually
had it a couple years ago but then
someone lost it I had stuff in my old
one I think a picture of my parents my
boy Brian oh you're a belt this is
actually a really cool piece because
this is discontinued I bought this like
a few years ago as you can tell it's
kind of like worn out by where there's
like almost every day I have like other
boats too but this is just like my go-to
can't really find them anymore you know
next essential is some earbuds Trey
beats I don't know I like these just for
like planes and stuff like I always wear
these on the plane like I always like
fall asleep with them am i hearing stuff
so I know like other people got like the
other ear pods and stuff but I'd
definitely lose those and how I found
out about these specifically I was on
the revolt panel like two years ago
and they gave me these as a gift and
then I just loved them I started using
them all time I've lost them a bunch of
times got new ones so shout out to Revo
showed up today man I was into like I
want you to like rap music and stuff and
if I'm just trying to go to sleep I'll
like put on some spa music spa music
yeah oceans calling music or something I
don't know I actually like it a lot puts
me in a great zone every time I'm on a
plane why do I want to be up on a plane
it's like the turbulence like it's crazy
I'd rather just go to sleep and wake up
in the next city it's big sense you know
[Music]
the next one keys get the ball one key
goes with this key is you know Roky car
key memory any Lambo truck knows in last
year when it came up my first first
first car with a cobalt mercedes-benz
c-class I don't know I like portable
xbox let's break down
I like bring this like on the road all
the time the TV so you know I can game
wherever I want a game what I'm playing
a lot now I play a lot of punk G call
duty Madden 2k all the sports games and
stuff I still play the old fight night I
like the 360 version I used to be
PlayStation ps1 ps2 and then I got Xbox
then from there 360 Xbox the next
essential is a watch doesn't matter what
watch it is you can be any watch it's
always good like as a man have a watch
on check the time you know there's
actually stopwatch - so if I need a time
someone or something
no honestly I don't I can use it for
like other things like how deep I am in
the water my phone so my phone you know
I could tell the time if my watch isn't
set
I think Twitter's my favorite I like
this motivational quotes page lastly but
not least is probably the most important
one god you know my best friend you
gotta have him with you keep God first
at all times you know I'm saying kick
you through your day hard day good day I
always thank God no matter what through
good and bad you having a good day bad
day always thank God he should be rate
up there you know
[Music]